[Music]
we all like come in laughing
guys i just said the funniest thing and
everyone's laughing at it
what would you say are we laughing um i
can't it's actually not appropriate are
we getting
off cameras we go on patreon to go here
yeah it was on their patreon which
actually was my patreon
their patreon is actually patreon.com
annie letterman it's so crazy
isn't that crazy yeah they get all the
profits i don't get anything
all right so i would you guys ever take
someone else with you on a blind date
yes would it be a blind date anymore
well because we might take like a third
wheel
yeah no no so weird yeah but then
they'll be like
on another table with the newspaper in
the holes
going like this is this about chicks
just wanting to be safe and [ __ ]
that kind of thing um i mean the way you
said that stuff you know that's like
bad where chicks trying to be [ __ ]
safe they're trying not to get raped and
murdered it's like so like
well they suddenly don't trust men it's
super strange should i get bangs or not
get murdered i don't know
what's the difference for guys it's more
like an escape
you said suddenly women don't trust men
yeah it's the weirdest thing
that's a phenomenon it's so funny that
you just reached the age where people
are terrified of you you're just
noticing that women
oh it's been like that for me for a
while i
now that i'm hearing of this i'm like
why would why have we not done this
i never even thought of that oh wait
bringing another person with you yeah on
a date
i think it ruins the dynamic i did
actually
we're a blind date to bring our ugly
friends your busted friend like
yeah that makes you look prettier
i was usually that friend yeah right
your friends must be
for the guys it was an escape it was
like
if if it's not working out then like you
got to come and save me
a guy bringing a guy yeah that's pretty
rough
i would be [ __ ] terrified if two guys
came i'm like
i know yeah but if you're a beta male
and you're like i want to have my alpha
buddy there just in case
oh my god but you know what it would be
it would be your alpha male's
friend's idea because it would never
have been your idea because
they would have been like me call bro
and like okay
don't peg me in front of her please okay
you can if you want dude imagine showing
up to a blind date though
and the person that you're having this
date with
ends up bringing 23 members of their
family to this day that's hilarious we
gotta say is that even a date anymore
it's more like a family reunion is this
like a mormon
blind is this an attempt that going
viral in china
oh [ __ ] there's one some mormon chinese
this one woman she decided to bring 23
of her family members along to this
blind date i don't know how loud was
that
23 in me is me trying to find 23 family
members
yeah so the the reason why she did this
was because she wanted to test out how
generous he is because
they just laid the the dinner bills oh
there's some chinese [ __ ] and it
came out to about three thousand dollars
that's a blind date though that's not
cool i don't know how do you wait
three people i'd be like this is you
know what a blind date means it means
uh you all close your eyes while i run
while the check is coming
out yeah this is a scam they probably do
this a lot to get this is so good did he
pay
please tell me he didn't well i had to
this is like a chinese [ __ ]
dick measuring contest well so this is
what happened he ended up
like once he showed up he saw family
members he's like oh okay
i gotta go to the bathroom and then when
he went to go check out the bill
and he saw that it was like almost three
thousand dollars he
just ended up leaving he's like [ __ ]
this i'm out smart man
so yep that's when uh he just left the
bill for them to pay
but then later on he and the the woman
ended up agreeing
that he would pay for the two tables he
was at
or like that were near him or whatever
and then the rest of the bulk of the
bill would be paid by her family members
how would he pay for the two tables
though like can he just pay for his own
[ __ ] yeah his own [ __ ]
this is called this is called dying die
die die die
i did want more like praise you guys are
disgusted you hate me you want me to
leave
but i was expecting to be held up on
like a chair like it was about mitzvah
but that's fine
here i'm imaginarily
i'm not jewish but i don't know the song
it was like
okay but yeah so then once um so then he
posted this
this story on china social media i'm not
gonna believe this but
it actually wasn't him he was getting
his phone fixed he was like can you
i don't want to ruin my honor with my
family so i need you to actually tell
people
what these people do oh [ __ ] i called
back another video
it's okay you guys you have to go back
you got to watch all of them that's
right
i was like no one's going to get that
it's so crazy obscure
wow you guys will find it you'll figure
it out which video she was referring to
yeah
on their patreon it's actually not on
their patreon but on their patreon
there's a lot of good stuff
so yeah so then they're saying like dude
that's [ __ ] up of the woman how the
[ __ ] is she gonna bring all her family
and expect this man to pay for
everything and then other people were
three thousand dollars that's [ __ ] up
yeah they weren't even eating light
that's a lot even better
first date too to be that committed and
then also the family had the audacity to
actually get upset
that this man wouldn't pay for the bill
all 23 of them got mad
well some of them apparently got really
angry the other ones were like
[ __ ] they were like what the [ __ ] we
didn't even drink was it even including
her
like was it 24 people including her or
was it twenty i know maybe
i think that was complicated she better
[Music]
yeah there's they never do you know they
never have we want to see it but she's
probably not that hot
then if he just bounced true
you think 3 000 yeah have you seen some
people
dude if she showed up and she's hot as
[ __ ] like ultimate 10
yeah and she brought all her family i
think the guy's figuring it out thank
you yeah
i think he's gonna figure it out he goes
to the bathroom he's selling some stocks
on his phone
he's like all right he's selling his
he shoes yeah he comes out completely
naked he's sold all of his clothes in
the bathroom
don't underestimate cheap guys you
underestimate horny dudes who want to
[ __ ] be with perfect tens bro uh-huh
uh-huh well i guess it's a battle
between who this guy is
is does is he super cheap or is he super
horny
true he's super cheap he's gonna have to
bang her in front of 23 of her family
members well not super cheap if he was
able to
pay for those two other tables like he
was more reasonable because it's like
[ __ ] that i'm not getting taken so he
wasn't that horny he
was the verdict she wasn't that hot i
don't know kind of hot but he got taken
to a [ __ ] negotiating table about
this later which is i would have just
been like shut the [ __ ] up
yeah block was this certain quarantine
too there should not be that many people
i know right true i think they lifted
quarantine out there
it feels good right no but you know when
i asked that initial question if you
guys would be
down and bring someone on a blind date
after
hearing all that i was like oh [ __ ] i
forgot that i actually did that i had
met some guy online
and i brought my cousin with me to go
meet him
yeah and then but he brought his kid and
because i had a kid too
that's not even a blind date really it's
like a wait he brought his kid and you
didn't bring her
my kid that's like a betrayal like let
me know yeah i didn't know gonna brought
my kid
your kids could hang out that's more
like a hangout was he at the table with
you guys
no so actually our blind date was
meeting at the mall
and i just walked around at the mall and
i was like 19.
oh okay that makes sense i was 19. you
going to the mall
yeah and then but then the weird thing
though i'm 19 and 18.
i'm both 19 and 18 i love them all no
but the weirdest thing of all to me was
that the entire
date he was only talking to my cousin
and i'm like
maybe he thought she was hotter she was
way younger she was like 16.
and then i was like oh my god you should
have hit on his son i know
you're like your son that's the part
where i think it ruins the dynamic
not because anyone's hot or anything but
because two people are
if they're uh if there's a blind date
happening
the the person in that's the third wheel
has the least stakes because they're not
worried about anything
so they can actually be themselves the
other two are trying to impress each
other or they're playing this weird game
like shy so like for him to talk to your
cousin it was just
maybe like it just made him more
comfortable to talk to someone's real
strength
saying too and that's actually what my
cousin was saying too he's been so smart
yes i told you i'm not number four no
you're not that smart
you're gonna have to look at another
video to know what we're referring to
about the number four thing because
oh wow guys this is gonna just keep
going this is gonna be a crazy one this
is like a choose your own adventure guys
you gotta figure out which
way to turn okay dude i heard that ryan
reynolds and big lively
hit it off like that because they were
on a double date and they were just like
[ __ ] zoomed in on each other oh but
they weren't definitely with other
people how
cute and so they were just like sparks
flying across the table and [ __ ] and
these two people are just like
it's undeniable i used to live in santa
fe new mexico
and it was it's such a small town that
you have to
surrender to everyone dating your exes
and stuff you have to be like
you have to notice when there's a
connection and honor you have to be like
all right i mean hopefully you're not on
a date with them when it happens but
there's fire between you we gotta let it
happen yeah
so i support that i want to know who
they were on the date with though i know
i do too so bad
true everyone [ __ ] each other famous
people too
i don't know it's gotta be famous people
come on we're not just double dating two
famous people two reggies
well two reggies imagine how nervous the
reggies must have been if they were
reggie's
and it's like oh they were like i hope
they don't date each other
it happened they're like oh mom grandma
sister brother cousins can you call 23
of you
they're not going to pay what would you
guys do if your date your blind age
showed up with one of their parents
oh weird that's just too weird for me
i'm out immediately out or do you just i
mean she's
unless she's like a scorching [ __ ]
pushing 11 10.
it depends on my mindset going into it
so if like let's say
prior to talking it seemed like she was
like long-term relationship material
she brings to mom i'm out i'm like this
is [ __ ] weird this is way off track
if we've been [ __ ] around the whole
time like as in just like jokes and like
messing around
she brings her mom now i'm like i'm
going into it as a playground i'm like
how can i
how can i make them fight somehow or how
can i like
create a really fun situation that's
entertaining for me if she's like
giselle bud shin hot
yeah i'd figure it out you love tom
brady you're so obsessed
no no you know what it is mary tom brady
i have a hatred for tom brady and it
made me love him
well the way he's cocky is so funny oh
yeah
we all know someone that um
online dated a girl overseas and then
when he went to go meet her
uh he showed up at the airport and then
my other buddy went to go pick him up
and no one knew
that he was gonna go out on this date
and then so he was already dressed up
ready to go
and then my friend thought that they
were gonna hang out and he's like
actually can you drop me off at the
docks
and then he went to the uh he went on
this and she was a mermaid
and she showed up with their parents oh
and my buddy
was like what the [ __ ] like this girl
looks hella [ __ ] young
damn and he went on a date with her and
her parents
and he booked this whole little boat
thing and then my other buddy was just
in the car watching the whole time for
like a couple of hours like what though
that's even weirder that he was there
well he was kind of
trapped into it because he was like what
the [ __ ] i thought we were gonna hang
out like you came for me
wow not even going there for him it was
for that girl
yeah when you set the story up i thought
you're like we all have a friend
like this like this is a relationship no
we all know this person i was like
nobody has a friend like this we know
this person
i'm just not telling them who it is yet
um that's
wild so then what happened with the girl
that we'll find out on patreon nope
okay join patreon no it didn't work out
and
yeah i i i don't even know if she was of
age but he was
like what the [ __ ] was that you'll
definitely find one what country was
this
he can't say canada oh wow yeah it was
overseas
yeah but when i heard the story from my
buddy i was like
what the [ __ ] this is crazy but you
don't want to say but should we tell the
police
they didn't hook up oh guys i'm a cop i
didn't tell you that oh there we go yeah
i keep it for hush hush people aren't
into me right now you [ __ ] narc yeah
they [ __ ] defunded me
bye